what I want to do in this video is go
over what I think is one of the more
intuitive ways to sort a list it's how I
would probably sort it if I had to do it
manually but I want to make it clear it
is not the most efficient way to sort a
list but let's just this I think it's a
good starting point where we get getting
warmed up with sorting lists so it's
called insertion sort
in assertion in assertion sorting I'm
going to give a graphical a graphical
description of the algorithm for
insertion sort and just so you know what
algorithm sounds like a very fancy word
but an algorithm is really just a way of
sorting it or a process for doing it or
a method for doing it a program is a
specific implementation of an algorithm
or it can be a specific implementation
of an algorithm once I have a general
algorithm I could implement it in Python
I can implement it in C I could
implement it in Java those are specific
programs but they'd all be implementing
the same way of doing the sort and
that's what I'm describing here the
insertion sort algorithm so let's just
start with a simple example let's say
that I have a list let's say I have a
Python list because we're going to be
working in Python for this and that list
is let's say it is 7 3 1 2 4 6 and so
the way that we do the way that we do
insertion sort is you go element by
element and then you compare it to the
elements before it and that you look for
the first element before it that it is
actually less than and then you just
stick it right over there so let me show
you what I'm talking about
so you could start with the set the 7
this is the 0th element over they over
here but when you look at when you start
with the 0th element you're like hey
wait there's nothing before it to
compare it to so it really doesn't make
sense to start with the zeroth element
so really if you were to implement this
algorithm you'll start it with the third
element or sorry he'll start it with
this if this is the zeroth element you'd
start it with the first element right
over here this is 0 through this is
first I know this can be a little
confusing when you refer to this is the
first element but this one's the 0th so
you start with this 3 here and then you
start comparing it to all of the
elements before it and as soon as you
find an element that 3 is less than you
stick it in that part of the lid
so what you do is you say okay is three
less than seven well yeah it is less
than seven so what you want to do is you
want to shift you want to shift seven
where the three is so let me let me put
out here so we're using we're trying to
compare three two everything before it
right now we're trying to compare three
two everything before it so you say okay
it's three less than seven yeah it is
less than seven so let's put the seven
where the three is so let's put the
seven where the three is and let's put
the three where the seven is and let's
put the three where the seven is
especially because there's nothing left
to compare the three to there's nothing
lower there's no elements before the
zeroth element so let's just stick the
three right over there and so our list
now looks like this our list now looks
like three seven one two four and six
and and one thing you'll find
interesting or something to pay
attention to is as we build this list so
we the zeroth element is is now
definitely less than the first element
and everything up to and including the
first element is now sorted everything
up to and including the first element is
now sorted and that will be true as we
keep going through this as we keep going
through higher and higher indexes up to
and including that index after we've
done that pass will be sorted and I'll
try to point that out as we go along so
we did the first index so we already did
the first index now we can move on to
the second to the second element which
is this one over here and so you take
that one I'll put it on the side right
over here you take that one and you
compare it to each of the elements
before it okay is one less than seven
sure one is less than seven so let's
take stick the seven where the one is
let's stick the seven where the one is
and then you could either put those you
could just keep comparing or you could
just stick the one where the seven is
and then you would say okay is one less
than three well yeah sure it's less than
three so let's stick the let's stick the
three where the one is and let's put the
one where the three is and let's put the
one where the three is so what is our
list now our list now is going to look
like our list now is going to be one
one three seven two four six
so notice after we've gotten to the enth
index so in this case this was the index
of two where that one was right over
there everything up to and including
that index is sorted this part right
here is sorted it's going to be other
things are going to be thrown in here
probably as we go on but so far this
part is sorted so you can see by the
time we get to the end of this list
everything is going to be sorted so
let's let's now go to the next index or
the next item in the list and that is
this two over here
that is the two over here and so we
compare the two to the 7/2 is definitely
less than the seven so let's put the
seven where the two is and let's put the
two where the seven is now you compare
the two to the three two is less than
three so let's put the three where the
two is and let's put the two where the
three is then compared to two one is two
less than one no it is not less than one
so we don't have to do anything else we
don't have to keep going to the left and
so now after this past and this past we
were comparing this to item two
everything before that so after this
past our list looks like this our list
looks like looks like one two three one
two three seven four six and notice
everything up to and including the the
third item so zero one two third item is
now sorted and now we're ready to look
at this at the next the next element in
the list and one thing I want to make
clear when you actually implement it
there's a couple of ways to do it you
don't always have to so in this example
we said hey two is less than seven we
had the seven replace where the two is
which you should do and then we had the
two replace where the seven is but the
reality is you can keep going down until
you find a good place to put the two and
shifting everything to the right as you
do it and then putting the two in
although this way it's a little bit
easier to keep track of and well maybe
we'll explore different ways to do it
when we actually implement the algorithm
anyway let's look at this for same exact
idea for is less than seven so let's put
the seven where the four is and put the
four where the seven is
is for less than three no it's not less
than three so we stop we're done now
everything up to and including up to
including the fourth item in this list
zero one two three four is now sorted
and now our list looks like let me
scroll down a little bit now our list
looks like this let me write it down it
is one two three one two three four
seven and then six and now we can go to
this last element in the list the last
element in the list this is the six that
we're now comparing actually the last
the last time we did this we were as a
four that we would cared about but now
we care about the six is six less than
seven sure it is so let's put seven
where the six is let's put a six where
the seven is is 6 less than four no it's
not and so we stop because we know that
this is going to be sorted if we went
any further we're going to get elements
that are less than or equal to four so
we are done we have sorted this list the
sorted list is now one two three four
six and seven in the next video I'm
actually going to try to implement this
algorithm that I just described and I'm
going to implement it in a in a simple
Python function